dolly parton i know you and i both wish
we could be with her right love dolly
well unfortunately we can't but our
tennessee queen rachel smith sure can
hey there rage
thank you for that nichelle but we all
know who the real queen is here
dolly parton honey i thought i had died
and gone to heaven
now miss dolly is telling stories we
have never heard about her private life
including her mysterious husband
some people think carl just doesn't even
exist
oh i know a lot of people have thought
that through the years because he does
not
want to be in the spotlight at all
oh he just hates that that's just not
who he is he said i didn't choose this
world i chose you
and you chose that world but we can keep
our lives separate and
and together we've been together 56
years married 54.
we got married again on our 50th
anniversary four years ago we got
all dressed up he was so handsome now he
tells everybody i'm his second
wife don't say that i don't want you to
say that
what's been the key the success well i
always joke about the fact when people
ask me why it's lasted this long i said
because i stay gone
and there's a lot of truth in that dolly
shares rare photos of carl in her new
visual memoir
dolly parton song teller my life and
lyrics
but when it came time to record her
first holiday album in 30 years
a holly dolly christmas she called on
some other family members like
goddaughter miley cyrus you've got billy
bray cyrus you've got
miley cyrus you've even got jimmy fallon
on there
like how did that come to be ollie and
billy ray of course are like family so
i wanted them but actually jimmy fallon
is the one that started that whole idea
of duet partners i watched him all the
time singing with all these people
and i'd seen he and miley sing i was in
the stream and i thought he
has really got a great
[Music]
a holly voice christmas come along yeah
i love it